from her comedic timing on Cheers to her
chemistry with John Travolta remembering
the life of Kirsty alley welcome to
Entertainment Tonight Michelle Turner
will join us in a few minutes from
London you know it was a shock to hear
the news of kirsty's passing from colon
cancer she was just 71 years young
Kirsty always kept us on our toes and
now we celebrate the life and laughter
of another star Gone Too Soon
I feel like I have the most blessed
wonderful for real fun life in the world
the days that I had here at cheers
they're the best days of my life
see myself being 95
doing movies or doing shows because I
really I really love doing it I am one
of those people that didn't think I'd
make it past 30. I thought I was going
to go down with uh rock stars you know
at 28. so every year to me is a bit of a
treat Kirsty was surrounded by her
family and had only recently discovered
that she had colon cancer in a statement
her children thanked the team of doctors
and nurses here at the Moffitt Cancer
Center in Tampa Florida we spoke today
to Dr Mark Friedman who practices there
you can be completely asymptomatic and
have colon cancer there's no one thing
that says you have this you have colon
cancer
how are you I'm good this was our last
interview with Kirsty it was in 2019 at
the premiere of The Fanatic which
starred her longtime friend and fellow
Scientologist John Travolta I'm so
excited to see him he's a chameleon
usually he's sort of a hero I don't
think he's a hero tonight John sheared
this throwback with Kirsty and described
their bond as quote one of the most
special relationships I've ever had
adding I love you Kirsty I know we will
see each other again with kirsty's
sudden passing John has now lost three
important women in his life all to
cancer all within the last two and a
half years wife Kelly Preston died from
breast cancer in July of 2020. the
disease also claimed the life of good
friend Olivia Newton-John who passed
away in August
I watched cheers on the set here and I
call Christy and tell her she did great
actor Parker Stevenson who was married
to Kirsty for 14 years shared this photo
and said I am so grateful for our years
together and for the two incredibly
beautiful children and now grandchildren
that we have and from cheers co-star Ted
Danson I am so sad and so grateful for
all the times she made me laugh
[Applause]
kirsty's last TV appearance was back in
April on the mass singer in September
she announced she had joined Cameo
offering video messages to fans if you
want something funny or you want
something sincere I would really try to
be sincere do you love all this magic
and glamor of Hollywood premieres yes
why because it's exciting from the first
time we met a 31 year old Kirsty in 1982
and in the 40 years since it was clear
she was full of life fun and always
incredibly candid my soul was dying I
was killing my essence of myself in 2012
she spoke to E.T about her addiction to
cocaine I thought I was going to
overdose almost every time I would do so
much at a time you know I'd snort the
Coke and then I'd sit there and I'd take
my pulse I'm dying I'm dying I'm dying
and who would keep doing it but it's
such a weird mind trippy addiction
Kirsty credited Scientology with helping
her get clean the plan was to come out
come to California and be an actress
but I didn't want to be a poor and
starving actress so that's where I went
on the game shows and I was an interior
designer but I didn't
have any clients here because I didn't
know anyone in California Kirsty made a
living doing game shows and bit Parts
like the love boat but she was 31 years
old when she got her big break as a
Vulcan in Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan
stand by project parabolic course to
avoid entering neutral zone I was
thrilled when I got Star Trek but I sort
of thought my first role would be like
body heat you know or something I didn't
know I'd be playing a Vulcan kirsty's
first comedic role came in 1987 she
played Mark Harmon's love interest in
summer school you mean the world's
sexiest man yes
very sick
Mark's a great guy does this mean we can
have dinner tonight I didn't say that
look about it over breakfast
I always fell in love with guys like
Mark
you know that we're totally
irresponsible I was totally
irresponsible and uh
school to me was where you went to meet
your next boyfriend making your way
but it was in the TV classic cheers
where Kirsty really came into her own
how do you do
Abu
at first I thought well do I want to be
not so much be in cheers but do I want
to go to work five days a week
she joined the ensemble in 1987 after
original cast member Shelley Long left
the show as Rebecca Howe Kirsty provided
the perfect love hate relationship for
Ted Danson's Sam Malone if me too had
been around when we did Cheers we would
all be in prison
really I'm not even kidding we used to
take nudies of each other we we'd kick
open the bathroom doors and take we were
horrible you can't even imagine the
stuff we did we'd stick each other's
tongues down each other's throats I mean
nobody was saying no don't do it but I'm
just saying yeah we would have been
sinking she's supposed to be with me
everybody
I'm gonna come down here a minute we
were with Kirsty many times on set and
for Milestone events including her Emmy
win in 1991. what is the winning this
one mean it means uh well it's a
wonderful acknowledgment of
of the work that I've done you know and
it but more than it means not losing
in 1989 to encourse these thin on chairs
she also landed the leading role in what
would be the most successful film of her
career whoa baby hot mama
what Charmed you into wanting to play it
um
I guess John because he's standing over
there no
it was John Look Who's Talking gross
more than 295 million worldwide two
sequels followed so did a decades-long
bond between Kirsty and John There's
real Sparks between you and Kirsty in
that in this movie did you feel that oh
all the time just had natural chemistry
I guess I love her as a person I really
do oh I look good
it looks slightly cute I didn't know
John before I took the film it's just
real easy for us but if Kirsty had her
way it would have been a whole lot more
I'd do another movie with him oh wait
are you telling us that uh he's sexy to
work with yeah it was you know I mean
it's I mean I'm married I can't go out
of control
she did have a crush on me before she
got married so therefore we were always
dealing with um this discomfort when it
came to like kissing and stuff now
that's entertaining in 2013 ET was
behind the scenes when she reunited with
John on her sitcom Kirsty how
much
that's where she told us her Travolta
Crush actually started way before look
who's talking here 's a real trip when I
moved to Hollywood I
was going to marry John Travolta and I'm
sure I'm the only woman in the world
that felt that way so when I met him at
my agent's house
I was trying to act I was trying to hold
it together a little bit I want to go
Cena I would have loved that Kirsty
later told us hey look who's talking
reboot would be a dream come true I'm
gonna try and convince him as you know
he's his own man he responds to money
and threats of course Kirsty also had a
close friendship with John's late wife
Kelly Preston we witnessed the piers
Bond during one of et's countless visits
to curse these homes that song is
addictive
it's so hot
the pair had a slumber party in Monkey
onesies at the Kansas native's Wichita
house this was four years after the
former Jenny Craig spokesperson
developed her own line of organic foods
I don't care if my If I gain some weight
and lose some weight I don't care what I
care about is never gaining 100 pounds
again Jenny I want to come home back in
2004 the diet program initially helped
Kirsty lose 75 pounds after a lifetime
of weight struggles most of my life I
was skinny and most of my life I felt
that what do you think they say oh my
God she's so freaking
I mean you know this you know they're
not just going she looks great
she even showed off her slim down on
Oprah the next time you go on national
TV in a bikini is
next lifetime really never again was it
a mistake no it wasn't a mistake you
gotta think of a new gimmick I'm not a
surgery girl
and you know why I mean I would have
faceless and stuff if you didn't have to
be put under anesthesia but anesthesia
freaks me out so you haven't had any
work done no I need some
do I look fat Kirsty never took herself
too seriously remember her Showtime
sitcom fat actress she was also
executive producer of the reality show
Kirsty Alley's Big Life the goal slim
down her 230 pound frame that's why
stop picking on me in 2010 Kirsty
invited E.T to her La home and
introduced us to her pet Lemurs hi
they're in my will
they're totally in my will the kids get
to live in the house and to lemurs own
the house Kirsty sold this Mansion last
year but before she held rehearsals
there with her dancing with the star's
partner Maxim shamarakovsky
does he give you any sympathy at all
him it's okay
after placing second the sometimes
contentious Partners reunited in 2012's
All-Star competition do you still talk
with Max do
those rehearsals do you miss working
with I don't miss the rehearsals at all
I'm shocked that people don't
die on the show am I gonna be the first
one that dies on Dancing with Stars
because it's so physical it's crazy last
night Max posted I thought you'd be
around forever I wish we spoke often I
love you even in her final TV appearance
the mass singer contestant vowed never
to slow down I have grandchildren and
they're really young so they're gonna
think this is good I don't ever want to
retire I want to work as an actress and
in other fields for the rest of my life
if I live to be 112 I plan on working an
eight-hour day at something so that's
one of my big goals
foreign